Harry: From portion sizes
to exclusive flavors,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Prime in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Let's start with Prime hydration.
In the UK, it comes in
a 500-milliliter bottle.
You can either buy this as a single bottle
or as part of a 12-pack.
In the US, our hydration
also comes in one size,
the 16.9-fluid-ounce
bottle, or 500 milliliters.
You can get it in options of one bottle;
an eight-pack, which
we did not get, sorry;
the 12-pack; and a 15-pack variety.
We also have Prime energy,
which in the UK comes
in a 330-milliliter can.
Just like Prime hydration, this
either comes as a single can
or as part of a 12-pack.
In the US, Prime energy
is a 12-fluid-ounce can,
or 355 milliliters,
and it comes in a single can, the 12-pack,
and a 24-pack.
In the US, our biggest
Prime hydration single item
by volume is this, the
15-drink variety pack.
Total fluid volume, 253.6 fluid ounces,
or 7,500 milliliters.
Our largest size is a 12-pack of bottles,
which adds up to 6 liters of Prime,
but that's still 20% less than
the biggest size in America.
And if you're going energy drink,
[grunts]
24 cans of these energy drinks.
This is 288 fluid ounces,
or 8,520 milliliters.
Our biggest Prime energy
item is, again, the 12-pack,
but remember that our cans
are slightly smaller than America's.
A 12-pack of Prime energy in the UK
adds up to 3,960 milliliters.
That's 53.5% smaller than
the biggest size in America.
Here are almost all of the
exclusive Prime products
you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
And here are all the Prime drinks
you'll find in the UK but not in the US.
There aren't any. Sorry, guys.
There are currently seven
flavors of Prime hydration
available in the UK.
However, all of them are
available in the US as well,
so none of them are actually exclusive.
That said, there are some subtle
differences in ingredients
when it's compared to the US,
and also, I've never had Prime before,
so I want to try all of
these, give you my thoughts,
and maybe rank them as well.
Here are currently three of the four
Prime hydration drinks
you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
So we got the lemonade, we got orange,
we have this LA Dodgers flavor
that might be just
specific to Los Angeles,
and there's a grape flavor,
couldn't get my hands on. Wah.
And here are all the other
flavors you can get in the US.
We'll start down here.
Lemon lime. I mean,
this, they're just going
after Gatorade on this one.
Wasn't that the first
Gatorade flavor, lemon lime?
Really sweet. Wow, that's really sweet.
Ice pop. But also, this looks like --
they have different names,
but I grew up calling them bomb pops.
I feel like I'm only tasting
the cherry in this one.
I think everyone who's
tried these has said it.
These are very sweet.
But, I mean, I'm kind of not surprised.
I mean, it's marketed towards kids.
Another thing I wanted to point out
is that I was able to find ice pop flavors
both in the UK version and the US version.
We're going to get more into ingredients
a little bit later on, but
I'll do a very quick taste
to see if there's any notable differences.
We'll start with the UK one.
And then we'll try the American version.
The flavors are broadly the same,
but the way that this one
kind of hits your taste buds,
it's very different,
and it's really weird.
When you consume a drink,
obviously you want to feel
like your thirst is being quenched.
You take a sip, and
there's something in here
that's actually kind of
drying my mouth out, almost.
I think if I had to pick
which one to prefer,
it is going to be the UK's,
and I'm not just saying that from bias.
Tropical punch. [grunts]
OK, I'm not ...
What the?
[groans]
All right, well, that's
pretty embarrassing.
Hope nobody's watching this.
I do like that.
No kidding, they're getting
progressively better
as we go through.
Can't screw up orange.
Mm.
Yeah, this might be my favorite one.
This is really good, and
this doesn't feel as sweet
as the other ones. Or am
I just getting used to it?
Like how your eyes adjust to the dark,
I think my tongue's
adjusting to the sweetness.
Of the many sports teams in the world
that have some sort of deal with Prime,
LA Dodgers is one of them.
Yeah, I've seen people on eBay
bidding a lot for these, so ...
Straight up, I don't
know what flavor this is,
but it's good. Do you want to try it?
My lips did touch it. Is it too weird?
We have a professional relationship.
Oh no, I've gotten used to it!
It's a good lemonade. As
far as lemon-flavored,
not-carbonated beverage, pretty good.
I was also able to get my hands on
one of the American exclusives,
the lemonade flavor.
I'm interested to try this
because the US and the UK
do have slightly differing
ideas of what lemonade is.
Obviously, in the UK,
we consider, generally,
lemonade to be a carbonated,
clear beverage, like a Sprite,
whereas in America, it's
usually just kind of
lemon juice, sugar,
and water combined, so.
It does taste a bit like you've let, like,
a Sprite kind of go flat.
You can probably keep this
one for the time being, guys.
Glowberry. It is supposed
to glow in the dark.
The label, not the beverage.
What the hell? Yeah, I
think that's the worst one.
That's really weird.
Meta moon. What is the vibe of this?
What about this says, like,
oh, that's so refreshing?
This tastes the way sunblock smells.
Strawberry watermelon, all right,
back to things I've heard of.
No, this tastes exactly like gum.
Bubblicious, like one of
those really fruity ones,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to start down this end
with the glowberry flavor.
Now, I did have to Google
this to see if glowberries
were an actual berry or not.
As far as I can tell, they are not.
I think it generally
refers to a berry flavor
and also the fact that the bottle
is supposed to glow in the dark.
I think we should put that to the test.
Charlie, hit the lights.
[laughing]
Not really glowing, is it? [laughs]
It's my first taste of Prime,
and it's not blowing my socks off, to say.
It's just a very artificial berry flavor.
Got a bit of tang to it.
Next up we've got strawberry watermelon.
I like that. The flavor I get from that
is almost more like a kind
of blue-Powerade-type flavor.
According to the label, the ice pop flavor
is supposed to taste like
cherry, lime, and blue raspberry.
Yeah, I mean, so far, the vibe I'm getting
is that they all just
taste of artificial fruit,
but I think in terms of,
like, balancing the flavors,
this one's done a pretty good job so far.
Maybe the most delicately
balanced flavor of the lot.
Next up, we've got meta moon.
Obviously, I don't know
what the moon tastes like,
and I don't know what the meta
tastes like right now either.
If there were a "Food Wars" meta,
yellow No. 5 would be S-tier right now.
Label just says this is candy-flavored,
which doesn't fill me with confidence,
because, like, which candy?
Tastes like Mark Zuckerberg.
No?
Like, at least these ones have had, like,
a fairly identifiable fruity flavor,
whereas this one is just
kind of generic sweet thing.
Then we're on to blue
raspberry, and one thing
that's immediately stuck
out to me is the color.
I think I was actually
expecting this to be
a more bright blue color,
but it's actually just kind of white.
It's quite a gentle blue raspberry.
I want a bit more acidity
from that, I think,
but it goes down very smoothly.
I do feel like I'm giving
Prime way too much credit here.
I'm swirling it around in a
glass like I'm a sommelier.
Maybe if we had a decanter
I could pour it out,
let it breathe a little bit.
I'm drinking too much Prime.
I'm going to be hydrated as hell.
I'm getting hopped up on Prime.
I need to go do a celebrity
boxing match or something.
Yeah? Joe, you down?
You and me in the ring,
the full 12 rounds?
I actually don't know who'd win that.
Who'd win the fight between me and Joe?
You back me? Charlie backs me.
Harry's vibe is very, like,
they're really always just
calm and reserved or whatever,
but that sarcasm that they
have over there, to me,
says that they're, like,
something's going on
underneath the surface
that they're suppressing,
so Harry strikes me as the type of guy
that if he got into a fight-fight,
he would just, like, black out,
and then come to, like,
in the middle of a field
at midnight with a
shovel, covered in blood,
with a corpse in his trunk.
I'll box him as long as it's supervised.
Moving swiftly on from
me and Joe fighting.
Next up, we've got tropical punch Prime.
Whoo! So, while I was
out in the US recently,
I was able to try Hawaiian Punch,
and that's basically exactly
what I'm getting from this.
And then finally, we've
got the lemon lime flavor.
Of all of these flavors, this is the one
that tastes the most
like it's supposed to.
If I had to rank them, I think I'd do it
in the following order.
I think my least favorite,
probably meta moon,
right in the middle here.
Meta moon is down there.
I think with ice pop,
they've just tried to combine
a bunch of flavors that don't necessarily
work together very well,
so I think that's actually
going to be my second to last.
I think blue raspberry is
going to come next for me,
and they lose points because
they didn't even try and color it.
I think next is going to be glowberry.
The bottle didn't really glow,
so maybe leave it in
the sun for a bit longer
if you're going to try that at home.
I think next up, we're going
to have tropical punch.
My No. 2 is lemon lime,
which means that my No.
1, strawberry watermelon.
My favorite's the orange.
In second place, I like
the Dodgers flavor.
Actually, now that I think about it,
I think I'm going to go here,
yeah. The lemonade's good.
And from here on, ice pop, eh.
I mean, yeah, lemon
lime, these are all like,
I'd grab any one of these.
These three, I'd say skip.
A little bit of flavor tweaking
or balancing might go a long way.
I think with some of
these, you wanted maybe
a bit more tang to them, bit more acidity,
maybe dial back the sweetness
on one or two as well.
I don't know if I would
necessarily pick a Prime
over a classic energy
drink, like a Powerade,
but I do think, in general,
if I wanted a sports drink
and I went into a store
and this was all they had,
I think I'd still be
happy to buy one then.
They're all fine, and they
kind of do that same job.
Next up, let's take a
look at Prime energy.
Now, while the Prime hydration drinks
are similar to maybe a Powerade,
these are much more similar
to a classic energy drink
like a Red Bull.
There is one exclusive energy drink flavor
in the US you can't get in the UK.
It is the original. That
just was announced this week.
Couldn't get it. Anyway,
here are the rest.
Yes, the UK also has them.
Most of them are similar
to the hydration flavors,
but there is a new one, orange mango.
I'm a bit apprehensive about trying these
because I don't drink energy drinks.
I don't even drink
coffee, I only drink tea,
and I think one of these contains
about as much caffeine
as three cups of tea, so.
We'll start with ice pop.
Chin-chin.
I think that does mirror the flavor
of the hydration drink pretty closely,
but I will say it tastes
better than, like,
a standard Red Bull flavor.
Strawberry watermelon.
I think there might be a theme here.
They just kind of taste
like fizzy versions of that.
Here's the new one, orange mango.
I get mostly mango. I'm not
getting much orange from that.
Yeah, not far off, like, a Rubicon.
Tropical punch is up next.
Yeah, I think that one's actually improved
by becoming an energy drink.
Lemon lime.
You could give me a glass of
that and a glass of Sprite,
and I'd struggle to tell
the difference, I think,
because it is just,
again, like, a carbonated
lemon and lime beverage.
Blue raspberry.
I actually think for a few of these,
just carbonating them has
actually made them better.
I think notably that was the
case with the tropical punch,
and also to a degree, I
think, blue raspberry.
One I could not get for
the time of filming this
was the ice pop.
Strawberry watermelon, though.
It's, like, sweet and tart.
Orange mango.
Somehow worse. Uh-oh.
So far, not good.
Tropical punch, OK.
Yeah, this one's good.
Lemon lime, ooh.
Yeah, it's pretty good, too.
Kind of tastes like Sprite.
Harry: Like some Sprite.
Blue raspberry, ooh.
Nah. Yeah, this one also has
a tart flavor to it that,
not that into it. So I think
I'm going to rank it like this.
Favorite was lemon lime,
really enjoyed the fruit punch,
blue raspberry is in the middle,
and then these two I wouldn't get.
I guess, wow, apparently the
strawberry watermelon flavor,
I'm just not digging.
Now, for the orange mango,
which was the worst,
something about it just
tastes like an armpit.
Ice pop, did not like
that one, I'm afraid.
Orange mango, fine, but
a bit too artificial,
and there are, I think, better
fizzy mango drinks out there in the UK.
Tropical punch and blue
raspberry were both improved,
I think, by making them fizzy,
but I think just in terms
of, like, flavor balance,
strawberry watermelon, undefeated.
One thing I will say about Prime energy
is that so far, when
I've been tasting these,
I feel like on the very
rare occasions when I drink,
like, a Red Bull or a Monster,
they have kind of a very
distinct flavor to them,
and even if you add flavorings to that,
it's hard to mask it completely,
whereas I don't really get a distinct
energy-drink flavor
throughout all of these.
Most of them actually
do just kind of taste
like fizzy versions of
the hydration drink.
I think it's actually quite impressive.
I think you probably could
drink them almost as a soda.
I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing.
I do think there's still
some room for improvement
with the flavors themselves,
I think particularly
down this end, of course,
but in general, I think they've done
a pretty good job with the flavors.
One product that we have
exclusively here in the US
are these Prime Hydration+ sticks.
These are like the
hydration flavors we have,
but in powder form,
and I think you can get it in
almost every single flavor.
I got two, four, six of the crowd.
Got six sticks.
OK.
Mm-hmm, OK. I mean, it
looks lemon-limey too.
I guess probably you're
supposed to shake it up,
and that's why you do a
water bottle and not a cup,
because look, it's all, like,
globulating at the top here.
Ah, very strong.
I think I could have cut
it with more water, but.
Oh, God.
Yeah, it's pretty close.
I mean, this is obviously stronger
because there's not as much water.
Sadly, the Prime Hydration+ sachets
have not hit UK shelves just yet,
although I can't say
I'm too mad about that.
I feel like, just buy
the drink, it's fine.
The price of Prime can vary wildly
depending on where or
when you are looking.
On the official UK website,
a 12-pack of Prime hydration
sells for £24.99.
That's around $31.82.
The per-bottle cost on
the website, therefore,
is just over £2.
In the US, that same pack is $29.99,
or £23.56,
so, not much of a price difference.
If you're not aware, Prime
is a brand of hydration
and energy drinks promoted
by the influencers
Logan Paul and KSI.
The two have amassed
a huge fan base online
through various ventures
on YouTube and podcasting,
music, and even wrestling.
Now, Prime is manufactured
by Congo Brands,
a company based out of
Louisville, Kentucky.
Paul and KSI are the primary
spokespeople for the brand.
When Prime launched over a year ago,
with KSI and Logan Paul
putting their celebrity weight
behind the promotion of the
brand, it was a huge success.
However, due to the
popularity of the drink,
a huge reselling market has emerged.
Prime came to the UK in June 2022
and was an immediate smash hit.
On release, Britain saw
teenagers queuing up
outside supermarkets all morning
to try and get their hands on some.
Places like Asda sold out
so quickly that they had
to implement a
three-bottle-per-customer limit.
Convenience stores realized
they could buy Prime in bulk
and flip individual
bottles for a huge markup.
Some, such as the
TikTok-famous Wakey Wines,
achieved infamy when they were caught
selling bottles or cans
for as much as £100 each.
KSI even had to step in at
one point and scold resellers,
saying that it was "not ethical."
It wasn't as bad over here.
It did fly off the
shelves for a little bit,
but I think it might've
had something to do with
the resale value of these
online was pretty good.
I've never seen anyone
drinking it, and, to be honest,
I got everything at Target
and online kind of no problem.
Now, currently, the LA Dodgers
limited-edition bottles
are pretty pricey on eBay.
I'm assuming, once again,
that has more to do
with its scarcity than its taste.
Even now as we film this, in October 2023,
the Prime market hasn't exactly
calmed all the way down.
For some of the more standard flavors,
the supply has now caught up with demand,
and you're able to find
them in most supermarkets
for the standard retail price.
For example, I was able to find the bottle
of strawberry watermelon
in Tesco for just £2.
However, for some of
the more exotic flavors,
the only places you can find
them are specialist candy shops
or niche resellers.
The only place I could
find my bottle of glowberry
was at one of those weird
American candy stores
which plague Central London.
This one bottle cost me £14.99.
I wouldn't have paid £18
for a bottle of Prime,
but you did expense it, so
you didn't pay for it either.
What is the most I would realistically pay
for a bottle of Prime hydration?
I don't know, 5 bucks?
You think 5 is high?
How much would you pay?
I've just been informed $5 is too high.
$1.50?! You can't get anything for $1.50.
What are you talking about?
Fine! I would pay as much
as Gatorade and Powerade
and all the other ades are for this.
It's hard to find empirical evidence
as to whether or not
the craze around Prime
has kind of died down, but
just from anecdotal evidence,
I really don't think it has.
Even when I was out buying
the Prime for this episode,
I would see kids in the
stores just taking selfies
with bottles of Prime
like it was a celebrity.
I think due to the
scarcity and the demand,
it's almost become like a status symbol
among certain generations of kids.
It's a race to see who
can get the new flavors
of Prime the fastest.
People will, I guess, empty them out
and just use them as water bottles
when they go to school, and again,
it's just kind of a way
to flex on your peers.
Besides converting their massive fan bases
into loyal customers,
KSI and Logan Paul have also been able
to translate this into
commercial partnerships.
Prime is now an official
drink supplier of the UFC,
the LA Dodgers, and Arsenal,
of which I believe KSI is a fan,
and they're also the official
sports-drink partners
of FC Barcelona and FC Bayern Munich.
We've seen other influencers capitalize
on their success in the
food-and-beverage space.
MrBeast, of course, has Beast Burger
and his chocolate bars, Feastables.
Emma Chamberlain has her coffee
brand, Chamberlain Coffee.
Now, according to Paul, in the first year,
the brand has cleared $250
million in retail sales.
Goodness.
Here are all the ingredients
for a Prime hydration
ice pop flavor in the UK.
These are the US hydration
ice pop ingredients.
The ingredients are
pretty similar overall.
The UK has slightly more coconut water,
10.5% compared to America's 10%,
but ours is actually
reconstituted from a powder,
whereas America's is from concentrate.
Prime hydration in both
countries, both zero added sugar,
but does contain artificial
sweeteners sucralose
and acelflame, no, that's not it,
acesulfame K, or ace K.
According to the Center for
Science in the Public Interest,
ace K raises health issues such as cancer,
hormone disruption, and
potential pregnancy risks.
Per Healthline, there is
also evidence suggesting
that acetoacetamide, a
compound formed in the body
during the breakdown of ace K,
may result in thyroid
damage in lab animals.
Now, ironically enough, the lack of sugar
may be an issue for the very
purpose of Prime hydration.
Electrolytes play a
crucial role in making sure
your body functions properly.
When you exercise or play hard, you sweat.
You lose not just water,
but you also lose important electrolytes.
Electrolytes are key to hydration,
and Prime does contain electrolytes
like magnesium and potassium.
But the low amount of
glucose may impair your body
from properly absorbing the electrolytes,
as glucose is useful in
transporting them to your cells.
Typically, you don't need glucose
to absorb electrolytes, but it does help.
Prime energy is currently
in hot water with the media
as well as the US government
because of its perceived
excessive levels of caffeine.
Here in the UK, our Prime energy cans
contain 140 milligrams of caffeine.
To put that into perspective,
a grande coffee from Starbucks
contains around 136.
Energy cans in the US, however,
contain 200 milligrams of caffeine,
which is a 42.9% increase from the UK can.
Because of this, Prime
is currently experiencing
a significant amount of backlash,
resulting in some shops
actually pulling it from shelves
in order to protect kids' health.
In July of this year, Sen. Chuck Schumer
called for an FDA probe of Prime
and said it was a "cauldron of caffeine"
that posed "serious
health concerns" for kids.
One Prime energy contains
200 milligrams of caffeine,
which is about as much
caffeine in a six-pack of Coke.
Says it right there on
legally the smallest font
you could put it in.
However, looking at the caffeine amounts
of some other drinks currently
on the market in the US
paints a slightly different picture.
Let's be clear: 200 milligrams in this can
is a lot of caffeine.
Pound for pound, it contains more caffeine
than Monster Energy or Red Bull,
but other American drinks,
such as Bang Energy
or Celsius Heat, contain
300 milligrams per can.
That's 50% more than Prime.
We don't have these in the UK.
I've never heard of
Bang or Celsius energy,
and they sound terrifying.
One distinction that Sen.
Schumer is highlighting
is that Prime is aimed at a kids market,
despite the fact that the can says,
"Not for children under the age of 18."
Now, if that is the case,
Prime still isn't the biggest offender.
G Fuel, a brand that appears
to also appeal to kids,
specifically in the gaming space,
has several drinks with
300 milligrams of caffeine.
They got flavors like
rainbow sherbet, snow cone,
hype sauce that contain
more caffeine than a Prime,
as well as celebrity-branded
flavors from PewDiePie
and someone or something
called One_Shot_Gurl.
Both have 300 milligrams
of caffeine in the can.
Where's the outrage for that?
A bottle of ice pop
Prime hydration in the US
contains all of this.
In the UK, a bottle of
ice pop Prime hydration
contains the following.
So in the UK, our Prime
has slightly more calories
but less sodium.
If you grab yourself a Prime energy,
I have the lemon lime flavor,
it contains all of this.
In the UK, the same drink,
albeit in a slightly smaller
can, contains the following.
So it's almost identical to America's,
although we have a little bit more sodium.
Charlie's correctly pointed out
that sachets would be way
better for the environment
because you're not using plastic waste,
so maybe I just hate the planet.
I'm sorry, Greta Thunberg and polar bears.
It's not personal.
So, am I going to make money flipping this
on Facebook or what?